- [Anuar] The humpback
whale, they're huge.
It's like seeing a bus in the water.
And she looks at you with those big eyes,
and she stares at you,
it feels beautiful.
And that's when you know
that she's letting you in.
- [Female Narrator] That's Anuar Patjane.
He's a photographer.
And in 2015 he won the grand prize in
National Geographic's
Traveler Photo contest
for his photo "Whale Whisperer."
So we're talking about
what it feels like to come
face to face with one of the
largest mammals on our planet.
- [Anuar] The first time,
it was in Roca Partida.
We knew we were gonna see the whales
because we were hearing them.
And when they are nearby,
your whole body resonates.
It's so strong.
I love the sound of the whales.
It's as beautiful as seeing them.
- [Female Narrator] He's underwater.
And off in the distance...
- [Anuar] I saw the
silhouette of the whale.
(whale noise)
Big, big silhouette that looks
like a submarine without features.
It's like a big object.
- [Female Narrator] And as he got closer,
things became clearer.
- [Anuar] Oh, there's
the eye, there's the fin.
Oh, that's a big whale.
It's a very big whale.
- [Female Narrator] The
most profound feeling he had
was a connection to the whale herself.
- [Anuar] She looks at
you. Right into your eyes.
And you feel the connection.
It is a mammal connection.
You feel accepted.
- [Female Narrator] Anuar's
been diving for 17 years.
And his photographs are
more than just pictures.
- [Anuar] Most of the photos
I make, I try to share them.
Because people that doesn't
dive and doesn't know the ocean,
they might start to pay
attention to the ocean.
And I like whales.
It's a reminder
that we share the world with
very, very wise and
beautiful animals down there.
(Whale sounds)